at first i was very insecure and unsure
of my sexuality and until i really
started to get support from my family
and the people around me i think i
really started to
become proud for me with all the drama
the nonsense of being on shows like this
those scenes
are so special and it's not like hey
look at me what look what a great mom i
am looking it's not about that it's
about saying
we're doing the best we can here's how
we're doing it talk about it with your
kids accept your kids if no one else is
loving you or taking care of you at the
very least the people that brought you
into this world and created you
should be there for you and i'm proud of
you i'm proud that you know who you are
and and if you want to fly a flag and
fly a huge one in your room fly the damn
flag
but i have seen some people say even
former castmates of mine say things like
oh you shouldn't bring this on for a
storyline let me be very clear about
something i'm not bringing anything on
as a storyline this is actually my life
which is the point of a reality show so
the thought that there's children out
there whose parents don't even accept
them just kills me
it just kills me come to my house i
truly do not believe i would be in this
position today if my parents also were
not supportive and accepting when i came
out i know how great it felt to be able
to go to my parents and discuss anything
yeah i'm very lucky that way i didn't
come from a family like that the family
i came from didn't talk about anything
and so you know for me it was of the you
know utmost importance to create a
family that could talk to each other
what do you think you can say to other
parents out there who may be struggling
with accepting their own queer children
man just listen the truth is they just
want to be heard they just want someone
to listen accept them and love them and
that's it
[Music]
you